parole est maintenant aux présidents
alain millions pour le groupe l'est
républicain devait la parole
merci monsieur président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre des
affaires sociales et de la santé les
soins de suite et de réadaptation
interviennent dans la rééducation d'un
patient traité pour une affection
médicale grave le bon fonctionnement de
cette activité est donc essentiel pour
les quelques 950 mille patients
accueillis chaque année dans ses
services publics et privés une réforme
est attendu et même souhaité par les
professionnels du secteur
son principe a d'ailleurs été votée en
décembre dernier il s'agit d'une réforme
intégrale du financement dans la mise en
place nécessitera de long de
transformation de la part des
établissements de santé
or ces établissements et plus
particulièrement ceux du secteur privé
s'inquiète de sa mise en oeuvre est en
effet particulièrement inquiétant pour
ces établissements qui reçoivent des
indications changeantes d'une semaine
sur l'autre de mesurer l'impact d'une
telle réforme
alors que celle ci doit rentrer en
vigueur en mars 2017
c'est d'ailleurs le constat que fait
olivier v rendant son rapport d'étape de
mai dernier dans lequel un produit des
doutes sur lavezzi sur la faisabilité
d'une telle réforme
l'évolution de la tarification des
établissements de santé est une
nécessité
et personne ne s'y oppose mais elle doit
être conduite en transparence et surtout
en concertation sous peine de crisper
des oppositions entre public et privé
qui n'ont pas lieu d'être
voire de faire échouer la réforme elle
même madame la ministre ma question est
donc simple
qu'attendez vous pour transmettre aux
établissements concernés les éléments
précis de sur cette réforme afin de leur
donner plus de lisibilité au risque de
déstabiliser l'organisation sanitaire et
de pénaliser les patients
merci la parole
pour vous répondre la dame marisol
touraine ministre des affaires sociales
et de la santé président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président alain milon je
veux d'abord vous dire que je suis
évidemment très attentive à la situation
que vous évoquez je vais y revenir dans
un instant cette situation je les ai
évoqué avec les établissements privés
eux mêmes à plusieurs reprises et encore
récemment puisque j'ai eu l'occasion de
recevoir il y a quelques semaines à
peine à la fois des représentants de
grands groupes d'établissements privés
et les représentants de la fédération de
l'hospitalisation privée
parmi les différents sujets que nous
avons à traiter il y a effectivement
celui de la mise en place de la réforme
annoncée depuis maintenant assez
longtemps des du financement des
établissements pratiquant des activités
de soins de suite et de réadaptation
des discussions sont engagées avec mes
services au ministère la direction
générale de l'offre de soins pour
arriver à identifier le bon dispositif
de financement
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire à mes
interlocuteurs que cette réforme se
mettrait en place dans les délais
attendus parce que cette réforme est
nécessaire ne serait-ce qu'en termes
d'équité entre les différents
établissements publics ou privés qui
réalise telle activité mais j'ai
également un dj et j'ai dit qu'il
fallait que nous puissions dans les
prochaines semaines apporter tous les
éléments attendus par les établissements
de soins de suite et de réadaptation
mais j'ai également indiqué que je serai
très attentive et que le ministère
serait très attentif pour que les
conditions de mise en oeuvre de cette
réforme ne déstabilise pas les
établissements privés
si pendant que la réforme se met en
place nous étions amenés à constater des
dysfonctionnements dans certains
établissements
nous entrons nous en tirerions alors les
conséquences vous le voyez monsieur le
président
la prudence est de mise
mais nous devons aller résolument vers
la mise en place de cette réforme le
président milon merci madame la ministre
oui merci monsieur prison madame la
ministre vous conviendrait quand même
que votre réponse n'est pas
satisfaisante et qu'il est difficile
pour les responsables de ces
établissements est nécessaire de
pénétrer et de comprendre les idées
développées par votre ministère sur la
facturation possible de ses suites de
soins de réadaptation
d'autant que ces établissements ont subi
depuis 2013 une baisse tarifaire cumulé
déjà 2 6%
cette difficulté de pénétration met en
danger de survie ces établissements
privés et surtout risque de priver de
soins
les 350 malades qui jusqu à présent
bénéficier de ces soins merci monsieur
le président